le foie porte demanda le ds on a eu
chaud nouvelle arme de dissuasion à la
bombe pétrole les céréales après la
convention socialiste de françois
mitterrand dans cartes sur table à 29
ans la messieurs bonsoir la france a
froid on avait un petit peu perdu
l'habitude depuis plus d'un an un froid
qui n'a rien d'exceptionnel mais qui a
quand même avoisiner les -10 degrés la
nuit dernière à nancy à lille apaire
montferrand saint-etienne dijon et
strasbourg et -7 à rennes ce qui
n'arrive pas souvent
la côte méditerranéenne est temps pour
le moment épargné alors cette vague de
froid a valu ce matin à l'edf une pointe
record jamais atteinte 41 1200 mégawatts
c'est à dire 3 cents de mieux qu'il ya
un an tout juste
mais le choc a été bien amortie
électricité de france attendait
visiblement à plus fort encore georges
leclercq le record de consommation
d'électricité battu ce matin ne signifie
pas qu edf est à la limite de ses moyens
de production car ce record est plus
faible que ce que l'on attendait chaque
année l'augmentation de consommation
avoisine les 6 % si vous prenez la
journée la plus chargée l'année dernière
qui était le 17 janvier
si vous augmentez la consommation
constatée ce jour là 2 6% et bien vous
êtes au dessus du record de ce matin en
fait pour qu'il y ait véritablement
journée de poing et situations
difficiles le froid ne suffit pas il
faut en plus intense ombre qui nécessite
beaucoup d'éclairage supplémentaire une
consommation industrielle accrue et une
sécheresse relative qui vide les
réservoirs d'eau des barrages qui
démarre instantanément
en ce moment il fait moins 8 degrés de
température moyenne mais le temps est
assez ensoleillé la grève des trains
ralentis un peu la consommation
industrielle et les barrages sont pleins
donc vous le voyez l'edf n'est pas
spécialement inquiète de ce record
demain ça ira encore et si le froid
persiste si le temps s'assombrit
il est possible qu'avec la fin de la
grève sncf le record de ce matin soit
battu mercredi
mais je veux dire que l'on constate un
phénomène dû au civisme des français
c'est l'étalement de la pointe
ça c'est très important car c'est la
pointe qui entraîne les coupures de
courant
délestage grâce aux campagnes télévisées
les usagers ne font plus fonctionner
tous leurs appareils ménagers en même
temps au plus mauvais moment
grâce aux tarifs recaler les industriels
en font autant
bref ça va mieux il reste à espérer que
nous n'aurons pas deux semaines de suite
de très grand froid que l'eau restera
c'est au derrière les barrages et que
les centrales nucléaires ne tomberont
pas trop en panne
en ce moment il ya pour compléter ce que
vous disiez georges clair sachez que la
consommation de pétrole a diminué de cet
ennemi % en france depuis 73 alors que
la production de nucléaire a accru de
170% quant au temps a prévu pour demain
puisque vous posiez la question il
restera froid mais claire sur la plus
grande partie du pays
attention nolito au brouillard givrant
et aux flocons de neige de la bretagne
aux flandres
de plus amples prévisions à la fin de ce
journal c'est donc dans le froid qu'une
bonne partie des usagers des chemins de
fer ont battu la semelle sur les quais
de gare aujourd'hui le mot d'ordre de
grève était en effet très suivie et peu
de trains circulent
ce soir encore le point maintenant avec
patricia cost est vide et jour noir pour
les usagers la sncf aujourd'hui avec 1
train sur 4 pour la banlieue a trait sur
5 pour les grandes vignes les grandes
relations des services certes mais
parfois une seule fois par jour
cela fait à trafic considérablement
réduit ce qui explique l'impact de ce
mouvement c'est que les rouleurs
autonome c'est-à-dire 95 % des
conducteurs de train
se sont joints aujourd'hui à la cgt et à
la cfdt en grève depuis vendredi soir
pourtant laurent revendications diffère
pour la fédération autonome
il s'agit surtout d'améliorer les
conditions de travail pour la cgt et la
cfdt
le problème est principalement celui du
second poste de conducteur qui doit
disparaître dans les crânes marchandises
et dont le début d'application a eu lieu
aujourd'hui sur la ligne paris marseille
pour les syndicats cette mesure devrait
entraîner la suppression de dix mille
postes et pour la sncf 5000 simplement
une grève qui devrait durer encore
demain toute la journée car elle a été
reconduite dans de nombreux dépôts
social toujours la firme talbot réduit
ses horaires de travail jusqu'en avril
prochain et ceci en prévision d'un recul
général des ventes d'automobiles en
france le travail quotidien chez talbot
sera réduit d'une heure et demi du lundi
au jeudi compris et six jours d'arrêt de
production seront répartis sur les trois
mois à venir
compensation relative 50% du salaire
prévu pour ses heures perdues les
commandes des constructeurs français ont
beaucoup chuté en novembre et en
décembre dernier et les usines
allemandes d'opel par exemple vont
fermer deux semaines en février mais le
pdg de renault sur tout à l'heure à
l'elysée n'envisage pas quant à lui de
réduire cette année sa production
un mot sur l'or pour vous dire que ce
matin encore on a battu un record
historique à londres 657 de la relance
j'en viens maintenant aux gros dossiers
internationaux de la journée est tout
d'abord à l'embargo américain sur les
céréales destinées à l'union soviétique
c'est une affaire qui constituera en
quelque sorte notre dossier du jour
edgard pisani au terme de nos reportages
viendra nous donner son point de vue
d'experts agricoles en matière
d'alimentation un peu partout dans le
monde en effet à l'image de ce qui se
passe en ce moment à hambourg en
allemagne fédérale des navires
soviétiques attendent le ventre vide des
céréales qu'on refuse de leur livrer
hambourg l'une des principales ouverture
de l'allemagne sur les grands espaces
marins doit aussi sa prospérité à son
rôle de pivot maritime entre l'est et
l'ouest
c'est ainsi que 1 2 3 4
au total une trentaine de bateaux
soviétique attendent patiemment leur
chargement de céréales venus des états
unis est provisoirement stockés dans le
port de hambourg
le deuxième port céréalier d'oran c'est
donc une vraie invasion de la vie
on dit qu'il s'agit pour ces bateaux de
charger le plus vite possible les
céréales américaines déjà livrés et
vendus avant l'embargo décidé par le
président carter acheminés par cargo
géants c'est blé et autres aliments pour
bétail sont en effet trier répartie ici
en comptage en distingue pour
l'allemagne fédérale d'une part l'europe
de l'est et lurs d'autres pas
on devine donc combien l'embargo us
grève aussi les intérêts des armateurs
et stocker hambourgeois le fait qu'il
poursuive encore leur travail ne leur
déplaît non pas les affaires sont les
affaires et le commerce a des raisons
que la raison d'état ne connaît pas mais
tout peut changer demain en cas de gêne
encore plus grave des relations est
ouest
hambourg est donc si l'on veut une sorte
de mini détroit d'ormuz un relais sur
une artère capitale pour l'urss
une grève des dockers peut donc étranglé
sinon pas l'approvisionnement de l'urss
en pétrole mais le plus de céréales
indispensables à l'équilibré alimentaire
des citoyens soviétiques et c'est encore
plus important des animaux dont ils
mangent la viande ainsi et même si
l'urss obtenait son blé d'ailleurs aux
états unis les deux cas de hambourg en
faisant grève avec leurs collègues
américains comme ils en ont l'intention
sont parfaitement capables de
sérieusement handicapé muscles la menace
n'inquiète guère du moins en apparence
il ya ni brejnev hier vous le savez il
disait que les soviétiques ne manquerait
pas d'un seul kilo de pain c'est vrai
nous dit un expert mais le consommateur
soviétique s'en ressentira quand même
car c'est le bétail qui va surtout pâtir
de l'embargo américain
il y aura donc moins de viande dans les
assiettes des soviétiques soviétique
devait importer cette année bref deux
entre 20 et 25 millions de tonnes de
maïs dont 15 à 20 en provenance de
l'union celui de des états unis et la
quantité qui va leur manquer qui va
manquer à l'appel vraisemblablement
d'ici la fin de l'année
il sera entre 10 et 15 millions de
tonnes soit entre 10 et 15% de leurs
besoins usuels pour l'alimentation du
bétail
traduit en kilo de viande consommée par
soviétique
cela veut dire environ 6 à 9 kilos a
personne dans l'année le soviétique à
consommer en 1979 60 kg si la
consommation si la production animale
devait diminuer dans le temps d'environ
10 à 15% la diminution serait de 6 à 9
kilos
une autre approche que l'on peut faire
conduit à penser que la diminution
pourrait même atteindre à l'extrême
c'est ce kilo ceci va évidemment
s'étaler dans le temps dit sa cage pour
cent c'est un mois un mois et demi de
consommation est en réalité ce n'est pas
avant
mois de juillet août qu'interviendrait
cette insuffisance pour l'alimentation
animale
mais alors qu'on avait très le bétail
l'emploi pas nourrir fait donc en termes
d'alimentation de la population domaine
animal il n'y aurait pas de problème à
cette époque là c'est à une plus longue
échéance
lorsqu'il faudrait reconstituer le
cheptel a battu qu'à seulement pour
exposer un problème mais on peut
imaginer que cela pourrait être
compensée par des importations de bétail
toute importation
les américains ne veulent pas s'en
arrêter là après s'être félicité du
soutien de ses alliés européens
notamment jimmy carter se prépare en
effet définir ce qu'ils appellent une
nouvelle doctrine à l'égard de l'urss de
washington jacques viguier a plus qu'a
fait qu'on appelle la doctrine truman
cela signifierait bon arrière de 30 ans
mais cela signifierait également que
l'amérique est prête à agir et à réagir
à toute expansion soviétique
au delà de ses propres frontières
aujourd'hui la mesure de rétorsion la
plus vigoureuse reste toutefois
l'embargo sur les céréales le ministre
de l'agriculture ayant rappelé hier soir
que moscou sera affecté très rapidement
par cette décision car les livraisons
américaines ne seront pas facilement
compenser par d'autres fournisseurs
utilisation de larmes du glay avait
provoqué beaucoup de réserve chez les
américains aujourd'hui la majorité
d'entre eux découvrent presque avec
stupeur plus l'argument est importante
et qu'il permettra de démontrer que les
états unis restent très puissante quand
ils investissent proposé au coeur aux
canaux ce dernier élément que nous
pouvons vous donner ce soir c'est une
information qui devrait vous stupéfié il
faut savoir en effet que les américains
ont besoin de connaître en permanence ce
qu'est l'état des récoltes soviétique
cela leur permettre d'ajuster en
conséquence et surtout d'avoir une bonne
évaluation des cours futur du blé pour
cela il dispose de satellites ultra
perfectionné qui dans quelques années
pourront vous donner au centimètre près
la taille d'un épi de blé soviétique à
quelques endroits que ça se passe c'est
ce qu'on appelle la télé détection et by
mess la forme des champs de blé est
actuellement très importante pour
pouvoir
à partir des satellites c'est ainsi que
les américains ont pour la première fois
à l'automne dernier réussi à évaluer à
moins de 10 % près les récoltes de blé
en urss en revanche ils ont tenu des
résultats médiocres pour leur propre
territoire
parce que leurs chansons souvent
entrecoupée d'autres plantations et
qu'il est impossible actuellement pour
un satellite de faire la différence
entre des champs de blé de maïs ou
autres céréales
si celles ci sont à moins de 100 mètres
les unes des autres
c'est ce que l'on appelle le pouvoir de
résolution du satellite pour les
américains c'est très important de
connaître à l'avancé les prévisions des
productions agricoles notamment en blé
parce que les cours sont établis environ
deux mois avant les récoltes à chicago
la télédétection pourrait être très
utile aux pays en voie de développement
en particulier pour savoir quoi planter
et où mais il ya de fortes réticences
soit pour des questions de technologie
soit pour des craintes d'espionnage
en effet les satellites de télédétection
demande une très grande technologie et
une finesse de plus en plus poussée dans
les observations si on veut espérer
suivre l'évolution de nombreuses
cultures évaluer les maladies s'il y en
a ou même faire des analyses de sol
tout cela sera possible bientôt et même
en france grâce à ariane et grâce aux
satellites spot grappes izany vous avez
féminiser la culture vous connaissez
bien les travaux de la fao à rome
l'organisme qui s'occupe d'alimentation
mondiale est ce que cette arme du blé
d'une manière générale de l'alimentation
vous paraît moral non quillan de voix
développé à cet aspect des choses un
très long propos l'idée même de se
servir de l'alimentation comme arme et
d'insupportable
je crois qu'il faut faire l'analyse
objective de ce qu'elle constitue cette
arme
d'abord elle se prépare elle se forge
comme tout autre âme pour avoir une arme
atomique pour avoir un canon pour avoir
un fusil faut du temps pour avoir la
hache
du temps de la pierre taillée il fallait
la taille est hélas les américains
comptablement de l'avant sur le
soviétique alors là les américains ont
forgé une arme non seulement à l'égard
des soviétiques mme à l'égard du monde
entier une forêt de façon
extraordinairement subtil et
intéressante non seulement en ayant des
réserves de production mais aussi en
faisant évoluer les agricultures de
chacune des régions du monde sur le
modèle américain et deux telle sorte que
s'accroissent la dépendance par rapport
à l'amérique et au canada je prends un
exemple en amenant les pays sous
développés à consommer du pain de 2000
ou de riz on les rend dépendants de pays
producteurs de blé en poussant l'europe
à produire du lait et de la viande à
partir de soja
on la rend dépendante des états unis
exportateur de soja en poussant la
russie a consommé de la céréale pour
faire de la viande on la rend dépendante
des états unis producteurs de céréales
cas le problème est tout de même très
intéressant en ce sens que la russie est
le pays du monde où l'un des pays du
monde l'un des pays du monde où la
production de céréales par tête
d'habitant est la plus élevée ce n'est
donc pas ébréché n'y a pas raison au
niveau de la consommation humaine que se
pose le problème de l'approvisionnement
céréales et au niveau de l'alimentation
animale et donc de la consommation
humaine de viande alors la russie se
trouve devant un choix très singulier et
très intéressant elle peut par priorité
abattre les porcs parce que le taux de
transformation des ports est extrêmement
parce que le taux de renouvellement des
ports après abattage est très rapide
elle peut au contraire à battre les
vaches parce que le taux de
transformation des bovins c'est à dire
le nombre de kilos de céréales qu'il
faut pour faire un kilo de bovins est
très élevé mais dans le premier cas si
elle peut reconstituer vite elle a un
problème d'approvisionnement
dans le second cas si l économie
beaucoup elle a un problème de
reconstitution c'est donc une arme
terriblement efficace non seulement à
l'égard de l'urss mais aussi vous le
dites de l'europe et des pays
sous-développés hôtel n'est pas efficace
dans le court terme car premièrement il
n'y a que les céréales qu'ils soient
frappés et les russes peuvent
parfaitement importer de la viande et
des produits laitiers qui ne sont pas
frappés par l'interdiction américaine
deuxièmement il y à d'autres aliments du
bétail
c'est le manioc et le manioc la russie
peut en trouver en thaïlande ou ailleurs
troisièmement il y à des pays sur le
marché libre mondiale qui pourront
exporter des céréales vers la russie
donc d'une certaine façon dans le court
terme c'est un peu un sabre de bois mais
je reviens sur mon idée première
l'arme alimentaire est une arme qui sur
le long terme peut faire que le monde
entier dépendra des états unis mais
seulement si le monde entier le veut
alors prenons l'europe si nous
continuons dans les faits à développer
des élevages portuaire dépendants les
importations de matières premières
alimentaires en provenance d'amérique
oui nous serons dépendants mais si nous
en revenons à notre système de
production plus classique à partir
d'herbes à partir de céréales
européennes
alors là nous ne dépendrons vous qui
êtes parlementaires européens à
strasbourg est ce que l'europe semble
aller dans le même sens que les
américains de quel point de vue du point
de vue de régler en bardeaux de
l'embargo où je pense que l'europe
n'ajoutera rien à ce que sont les états
unis mais ne s'interdira pas de
respecter le même comportement politique
mais les choses sont encore incertaines
je remercie
c'est donc une conséquence de la sphère
afghane ce n'est pas la seule en grande
bretagne le golvan satcher vient
d'adopter une position extrêmement ferme
l'invasion soviétique constitue une
aventure étrangères sans précédent dit
il qui appelle une réponse ferme et
concertée pour en éviter la répétition
conséquence également en france à
l'intérieur du parti communiste et
surtout entre les deux principaux
parti de gauche françois mitterrand qui
sera dans un quart d'heure l'invité de
jean-pierre elkabbach et bal annuel dans
cartes sur table pourra développer le
dossier sa pensée entre autres sujets et
pour sa part le radical de gauche
françois loncle a dénoncé ce qu'il
appelle le comportement insensé de
georges marchais et du parti communiste
nous avons vu une image du studio 101 où
va se dérouler tout à leurs cartes sur
table françois mitterrand pourra
peut-être répondre à ce communiqué du
parti communiste qui vient de tomber à
l'instant même connu qui est extrêmement
dur sur ce qu'il appelle l'opération de
grande violence monte contre le pc et
contre son socata général par la
propagande bourgeoise le communiqué
condamne violemment l'attitude des
médias français de la presse de la
télévision coupable de transformer tout
ce que dit le parti communiste et
condamne aussi extrêmement violemment ce
que dit le parti socialiste qui très
souvent va même au delà de ce que
pensent l'elysée dit monsieur georges
marchais donc d'une façon générale le
parti communiste réponse de françois mi
temps sur ce sujet le gars pisani dans
quelques minutes c'est à dire dans le
car sur table vers 20h35
deuxième gros points chauds à l'étranger
l'iran on vient d'apprendre que tous les
journalistes américains allaient être
expulsés très rapidement pour avoir
diffusé des nouvelles partial sur le
pays les autres journalistes étrangers
se contente pour l'instant d'un
avertissement est pourtant difficile de
nier que la situation dans le sud du
pays notamment à tabriz est assez
critique pour l'actuel gouvernement
voici ce que fut la réaction des
partisans de l'ayatollah shariatmadari
après l'exécution de onze de leurs
camarades les premiers morts de la
révolution
n'ayant pas appartenu de près ou de loin
à l'ancien régime
plusieurs centaines de partisans de
l'ayatollah shariatmadari favorable à
l'autonomie de l'azerbaïdjan ont
manifesté hier dans le centre de tabriz
ils protestaient contre l'exécution de
onze de leurs camarades condamnés à mort
par les tribunaux islamiques de commenee
après une nuit de combats de rue en
autonomistes et gardiens de la
révolution
comines il avait ordonné aux commerçants
de rester ouverts les manifestants
fermer deux forces
plusieurs boutiques avant de s'attaquer
à des symboles du pouvoir central des
manifestants jeunes et surtout sans arme
autre que des cailloux des barres de fer
donc si la foule a pu saccager et piller
c'est tout simplement parce que les
gardiens de la révolution disposant
d'armes lourdes ne sont pas intervenus
le siège de la banque melli a été
détruit et incendié aux cris de nous
sommes maîtres chez nous nous obéissons
à sharjah tu m'as dari et à personne dit
depuis quelques jours tabriz devenu le
symbole de l'opposition a commis à
l'intérieur même de l'iran hier le
gouvernement islamique de téhéran a
laissé faire mais de nouveaux
affrontements sanglants peuvent les 4 et
hattab et à n'importe quel moment à
l'étranger toujours en bref un
détournement d'avion tout à l'heure
entre rome et tunis
l'appareil d'alitalia a atterri il y à
une heure sur l'aéroport de palerme en
sicile il y aurait au moins deux pirates
de l'air l'un d'entre eux s'est adressée
en français à la tour de contrôle il y à
80 passagers à bord victor vraiment m'a
téléphoné pour m'annoncer la nouvelle
tout à l'heure nous rappellera peut-être
d'ici la fin de ce journal s'il y un
développement à ce détournement qui a
lieu pour l'instant jeudi à palerme
et puis la santé du marché à tito qui
vit désormais avec une portion d'artères
artificielle dans la jambe gauche
le maréchal dont la télévision
yougoslave nous adresser tout à l'heure
les toutes dernières images publiques
c'était lors du réveillon du nouvel an
il se déplaçait vous loyers déjà
difficilement serait dans un état
stationnaire mais certains médecins dans
toi toujours le terme d'amputations
possible ouverture aujourd'hui à rome du
synode des évêques des pays bas l'église
catholique néerlandaise apparaît divisée
entre les conservateurs et les
progressistes la plupart des
ecclésiastiques
néerlandais pardon de même que les laïcs
ont des positions plus libérales que le
vatican notamment sur le mariage des
prêtres sur le sacerdoce des femmes et
sur le contrôle de la natalité
visiblement le pape que nous voyons ici
ouvrir les travaux des évêques
néerlandais à rome on t'en remettre un
petit peu d'ordre dans son église bata
les prisons françaises sont surpeuplés
les détenus n'ont pas de travail les
suicides augmentent mais les échecs des
permissions de sortie diminue ainsi que
les évasions
voici les principaux éléments du rapport
de l'administration pénitentiaire pour
l'année 78 que publie aujourd'hui le
ministère de la justice au 1er janvier
79 il y avait dans les prisons plus de
33000 détenus dont douze mille qui
n'était pas encore jugé occupation qui
viennent se termine à l'instant du siège
de l'inserm l'institut national
scientifique d'étude et de recherche
médicale les personnels se plaignent des
conditions de travail et d'emploi dans
le domaine scientifique
situation calme ce soir encore en corse
on avait cru un moment que le commandant
bertolini avait été transféré dans un
hôpital mais il se confirme ce soir il
n'a jamais quitté la prison d'ajaccio
pendant ce temps à fréjus l'inhumation
de philippe marangoni l'une des deux
victimes civiles des événements
d'ajaccio de la semaine dernière et puis
pratiquement en même temps se déroule
est à montauban les obsèques du crs
hubert massol tués au cours des mêmes
événements
cette cérémonie se déroulait en présence
de christian bonnet le ministre de
l'intérieur
oui
des singes et des cochons vivants
utilisé en france pour des expériences
destinées à améliorer la sécurité
routière c'est une révélation d'un
magazine anglais l'observeur confirmé
dans ses grandes lignes par l'office
français de sécurité routière pas d'ours
en revanche comme on l'a cru un moment
une affaire qui peut choquer les amis
des animaux alors voici les explications
des chercheurs de ce centre lyonnais
association régie par la loi de 1901
donc sans but lucratif
l'office national de sécurité routière a
été créé il y a dix huit ans à bron dans
la banlieue lyonnaise
son but étudier tous les moyens
permettant d'améliorer la sécurité
routière est susceptible de réduire les
conséquences des accidents
à titre d'exemple le laboratoire a
participé à la mise au point des
ceintures de sécurité
il travaille actuellement sur un modèle
qui éviterait les fractures de côtes ou
de clavicule il a contribué à
l'amélioration des systèmes d'absorption
et de répartition des chocs sur les
voitures modernes
enfin il étudie deux nouveaux modèles de
glissières et définit les normes
européennes en matière de sécurité
les travaux menés à lyon sont en grande
partie financé par la communauté
économique et leur résultat profite à
tous
seulement pour obtenir ces résultats les
chercheurs de losne seurre ils sont une
quarantaine environ utilisent des
cadavres humains et des animaux vivants
peut-on faire autrement et utiliser
uniquement des mannequins non répond le
responsable du laboratoire de
l'utilisation des cadavres
art est tout à fait indispensable du
fait de la l'identité anatomique qui
existe entre le cadavre et l'individu
vivent ces cadavres nous sont fournies
par la faculté de médecine de
laboratoire d'anatomie ce sont en
général des personnes qui ont fait don
de leur corps à la science
en ce qui concerne les animaux le
laboratoire utilise effectivement une
variété de porn 1 ce matériel biologique
vivent est indispensable pour mesurer
certains paramètres cardiaques et
cérébraux les animaux avant l'expérience
subi une injection de produits
anesthésiants après le choc
ils sont sacrifiés et autopsiés les
informations ainsi recueillies sont
indispensables pour améliorer la
sécurité de l'homme est impossible avec
un mannequin
la campagne menée contre l'utilisation
d'animaux de laboratoire n'est pas dénué
d'une certaine hypocrisie conventionnel
ici ce sont les anglais qui ont tiré les
premiers
ils se sont scandalisés si ils répugnent
à commettre de telles atrocités
ils sont les premiers à s'intéresser aux
résultats des études qu'ils financent en
partie sport maintenant une information
à confirmer qui vient nous être
téléphoné à l'instant le forfait de
gourdon qui ne jouerait pas contre
l'équipe de galles france gall a lieu
vous le savez samedi et gourdon serait
victime d'un claquage l'impression que
nous vérifions pour l'instant et puis à
la limite du sport et la télévision hier
et avant-hier se dérouler à isola 2000
la coupe interviennent antennes de la
très bonne figure face à sa concurrente
tf1
ils vont sergent a gagné l'épreuve de
luge caroline villard celle de la
conduite sur glace et christine izard ni
celle du tir au pistolet et j'ai eu le
plaisir de recevoir pour notre chaîne le
trophée du biathlon il est juste quand
même de dire que tf a remporté le rallye
de ski et la conduite moto sur glace
découvertes au large d'alexandrie en
egypte d'un temple où auraient habité
cléopâtre et marc antoine c'est en effet
ce que pensent avoir trouvé une équipe
d'archéologues californien on n'en sait
pas plus pour l'instant
il suffit de voir ce qui reste dans ce
temple mai
c'est promis je vous tiendrai au courant
pas ce sont des images assez
impressionnante
la météo maintenant comme je vous le
disais au début de ce journal il a fait
un temps froid et sec aujourd'hui sur
toute la france pour demain pas beaucoup
d'améliorations attendre ce temps froid
persistera
mais de la bretagne aux flandres le ciel
sera assez nuageux des pluies
s'abattront près des côtes on nous
annonce également dans l'intérieur du
pays et en montagne des chutes de neige
au prochain rendez vous avec la
formation tout d'abord bien sûr cartes
sur table françois mitterrand répondre
aux questions de jean pierre elkabbach
et d'alain duhamel et puis vers 23h20
vous retrouverez pierre-alain demain à
12h45 antennes de midi avec patrick
lecocq qui aura comme invité renée du
boss qui est biologiste ainsi que rené
dumont et henri-laborit l'un des
principaux thèmes évoqués au cours de
cette édition l'homme et la nature
et puis aussi les problèmes nucléaires
mais ce journal est pas tout à fait
terminé nous allons faire en chansons
avec henri tachan qui est à partir de ce
soir et pour une durée de 15 jours
la vedette de l'olympia l'olympia où
nous nous rendons actuellement en état
chance c'est la deuxième fois vous fait
l'olympia en en un an
vous sortez j'ai vu ça un livre en tout
cas on édite un livre sur vous avec des
illustrations de cabu 2 gb de réserve de
wolinski 12 mans vous arrivez dans
l'anthologie de la poésie de la chanson
française ce que vous ne vous sentez pas
un peu institutionnalisée
nous ferons pas parce que je pense qu on
institutionnalise est lorsqu'on est
édité dans une collection si bleu aux
heureux au poète ou chanteurs et la
chance que j'ai justement c'est de
pouvoir être édité à charlie hebdo par
thiery dans la bande de charlie qui est
une édition si vous l'aviez pas du tout
habituée à faire ce genre de choses et
c'est ça qui est amusant mais évocation
de marginalité se termine quand même
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas je dirais ça
dans deux heures peut-être henri tachan
votre engagement
on vous a affublé d'à peu près toutes
les étiquettes politiques vous voulez
vous voulez quoi indépendant ni gauche
ni centre ni droite dans une de mes dans
un de mes textes je dis dans mon parti
il ya que moi et c'est déjà le maire d
ça résume touche quoi à vos côtés
georges v go oui je voudrais dire que
henri tachan aussi est à contre-courant
à une époque où tout le monde emploie
des orchestrations de plus en plus
volumineuse il va se présenter ce soir
avec onze chansons nouvelles et un seul
pianiste pour l'accompagner alors en
vertu de quel principe d'abord quel
pianiste jeudi quand on est un pianiste
comme jean lesage
ça remplace allègrement un orchestre
philharmonique où un orchestre d'un
autre ordre
non je crois que je suis très solide
très solitaire sur scène et j'aime bien
travailler seul j'aime bien ce métier
solitaire en fin de compte même si ça
c'est pas toujours facile d'être seul
face aux gens mais là j'ai un pianiste
alain quiros mousse tous les deux
vraiment si on se complète une connaît
par coeur je vous dis je le connais très
bien et c'est extraordinaire en plus ils
jouent très très très bien donc
eh bien on va le découvrir dans ces
quelques images que nous avons tourné en
répétition sur la scène même de
l'olympia nous allons le découvrir
pendant quelques instants et on va vous
écouter chanter une partie hélas de la
tendresse
c'est bien moins hot hot maladie c'est
tout au four
enfouie attendra son
sas a fait droit qu'aux parts dans ce
rapport fera trente plus tard de tourner
dessus
ce qu'on avait en essence lorsque l'on
est innocent latendresse
ce tout ce qui nous reste encore pour
faire un pied de nez à la mort tout doux
le
la tombe
oh
henri tachan dans quelques minutes à
l'olympia il dit visiblement mort de
peur pour l'instant où il se trouve
plein de choses avant de refermer tout à
fait ce journal j'apprends à l'instant
l'augmentation des tarifs des taxis
parisiens 10% de plus à compter du 16
janvier dans quelques jours donc pas
c'est néanmoins une très bonne fin de
soirée je vous retrouverai avec pédiatre
demain à 20 heures au ventre